تواصل القوات الروسيه البحث عن العديد من
الاستراتيجيات وتكتيكيات الحربيه التي
يمكن ان تساعدها في قلبي معادله الحرب
لصالحها فمع تصاعدي حده التوتر حوله هجوم
الروسيه الجديد تقوم مرتزقه فاكنير في
مدينه باخموت من الناحيه الجنوبيه بتنفيذ
العديد من الهجمات على الجيش الاوكراني
بحيث نفذت هجوما في بخموط وهجوم اخر على
محور اليمن وهنا سيسمح بالاستلاء او سيسمح
الاستيلاء على مارينكا للقوات الروسيه
بتجاوز فولدار الى الجنوب الغربي والتقدم
الى الشمال الاقاربي نحو قوه خوفو او كره
خوفه وهي مركز نقل اوكراني رئيسي
كما افادت مصادر عسكريه في دونيتسك بان
القوات المواليه لروسيا توسيطر على مدينه
مريكا شمال غرب المقاطعه وتدفع القوات
الاوكرانيه للانسحاب كما يوصل الجيش
الروسي القصف في مدينه
افديفكا شمال غرب مقاطعه دوناتس ويحاولوا
الدخول من اطراف المدينه اما في بلده كلشي
فيكا
جنوب مدينه باخمود والتي تشهد معارك دار
بين الطرفين الروسي والاوكراني فعلى الرغم
من سيطره القوات الروسيه على المناطق
الشماليه الشرقيه والجنوبيه للبلده
والسيطره ايضا على كاملي خطوط الامداد بما
فيها سكك الحديد الا ان الجيش الاوكراني
لم ينسحب حتى الان من كلاش اوف
ويتحسن في بلده ايفانوسكي المتخمه
وحسب تقارير امنيه فان روسيا تواصل توسيع
نفوذها من شبه الجزيره من شبه جزيره القرم
الى ضواحي روستوف جنبا فيما تحصن اوكرانيا
ترسانتها العسكريه باسلحه اوروبيه
وامريكيه لاخراج القوات الروسيه من
اراضيها خبراء عسكريون واميون قالوا ان
وقفه حرب اوكرانيا يصطدم بعراقيل ابرزها
تشديد الاوكرانيين على خروج روسيا من
اراضيها كما دخلتها اول مره وانسحاب
الجنود الروس من اقليم بس بالكامل
[موسيقى]